foreign
[Music]
dog are you a statue
is it real
you just gonna sit down what's up man
what's up man you're sharp as hell today
you clean man me what's how you doing
James nice to meet you
I heard you with a man in the city I
wear this all day long this is like my
uniform every day really you have
50 of those in the closet I have like 90
suits the same
they kind of all look the same but then
they're various shades of blue and then
gray and then pinstripe because it's
just all I wear
how tall are you I'm as tall as you I'm
about this tall
Ryan I'm two chains obviously I'm a
legendary iconic fixture in the hip-hop
Community uh yes you can stop me at any
time I love the tube you can keep it you
can keep going I agree with all those
yes and I'm also a really really awesome
host for this show most expensive is
right yeah I used to see brown stones on
television shows you know years ago like
they symbolized
at least middle class yeah can you kind
of tell us what the market has been
doing when you join the market what
makes what you do like success just give
us a rundown
that's a New York was founded by the
immigrants that came here that built the
city and it's a Dutch City so that's why
the streets are all over the place it's
a Trader City really is what it is right
and so then you had a lot of tenement
buildings a lot of uh you know apartment
buildings which is what all of this was
you know and slowly but surely as people
traded more and more Goods you know it
started with pelts and then flowers and
different types of goods and eventually
it got into financial investments back
in the day with Wall Street now this
house is on the market this is 80
Washington place or right off Washington
Square Park it's a really really really
valuable location valuable Street we're
in the village which is where everybody
wants to be so we're asking 25 million
dollars for this house for the one are
we in uh
screw so this is about 9 000 square feet
six floors 10 000 square feet six floors
six floors so these townhouses are very
vertical yeah that's what it is New York
they build straight up a lot here yeah
so much and no yard zero yard here oh
there's a this yard here there's no
grass
I'll show it to you most houses do have
some grass this house is set up for
entertaining so you have your double
height ceilings a lot of exposed brick
like this was done by Coda design and
what's really really cool is they kind
of took
everything you'd want in like a Tribeca
Loft so super industrial exposed steel
yeah right steel mantles a lot of
concrete and then they mixed it with
kind of what you would want out of a a
Village townhouse it's a cool house man
so I'm excited to show it to you
so you have these bamboo trees that kind
of are growing up to create some privacy
and you've got your outdoor fireplace a
full outdoor build kitchen this whole
window wall behind us and then if you
look over here it just started to be
fall but these are skylights so you can
look down into the lower level and I'll
show you this is like the movie theater
and hangout room down below I can see
people hanging out here late you know
getting uh
people have definitely hung out in this
house late
[Music]
laughs
and this house is 25 million dollars
brother 25 million dollars it's about 23
feet wide this is what I sell I just
sold a house on the Upper East Side on
68th Street I sold it it's a little bit
smaller than this actually smaller than
this and I just sold it for 57 million
dollars over FaceTime
so this is actually a great deal it's
one of the most expensive townhouses to
ever sell in New York City we need to
work together let's do it let's walk
around and see what else you got people
who don't know New York like if you want
a house in New York City it's very
expensive like if you want to be on this
block you can't get onto this block for
less than 20 million dollars
right and if you want to be by this park
and then you have to be willing to live
vertically and so I lost you you stand
you're standing back there
every house on this block is 20 million
those are the comps yep like that's what
you that's that's are you serious some
of these are not 20. so some of these
are still apartment buildings that would
sell for between 8 and 12.
so for 8 to 12 million dollars you've
got to buy an apartment building and
then you get to renovate it what's the
most expensive property that you've
dealt with so in terms of like one
single home selling the house on Central
Park right now is 250 million that's the
most expensive I just sold a place in
Palm Beach on the water for just under
140 million so that's one of the most
expensive homes to ever sell in the
United States
wow you're doing good Ryan man so out of
100 million let's just keep it even
because we don't want everybody in your
business I want to know what do you
what do you take home three percent
okay sometimes more
sometimes a little less but
you know in the words of the Joker
when you're good at something never do
it for free
all right let's go inside
you walk right in off the streets and
you're basically transported into
another world in this town absolutely I
love that right so you've got induction
stove so it's all melee so you can have
it cooking water but if you put your
hand there you're not going to get hurt
you have a private elevator in your own
house that's going up and down every
single floor we can go upstairs you get
this beautiful glass architectural
staircase
all the way up
why didn't you put me on the elevator
today is not leg day
[Music]
so this is the whole primary floor this
is a really cool kind of opening
dressing room and they use this kind of
as an office
and so in townhouses like this an entire
floor will just go to the primary Suite
there's a huge open kind of bathroom
experience here oh my God so this is
your jacuzzi tub you've got your trough
sink double tons of storage behind us
again like you can have a party in here
make it a bubble bath got the bedroom
there you got a little outdoor space
it's nice this is a little sexy setup
it's nice right yeah it is yeah I mean
this entire floor is just for this
bedroom anywhere else around here this
is
four million dollars as an apartment
just for this just for this floor just
for this floor so that's when you start
to get the idea like oh okay
this time six correct the cost to build
in New York City like let's say this was
six apartments right now and you wanted
to convert it to single family you're
gonna buy this and then the renovation
costs are going to be a thousand to
twelve hundred dollars per square foot
so for every foot like this you're
spending a thousand dollars everywhere
throughout the whole house to renovate
it because renovation costs are so high
so for 9 000 square feet here your hard
cost just to do construction everything
it's gonna be nine ten million dollars
10 million dollars yeah it's crazy
another floor so now you have another
guest apartments up here guest bedroom
guest Suites but this is cool because
you have your own
sauna oh yes so this is where you bring
your masseuse oh you come up here you
get a workout in downstairs you got the
table here you got a full dry sauna in
here you got a steam shower you rinse
off and then you got your outdoor space
here with a hot tub underneath the Stars
that's a scale
[Laughter]
is that what this is
[Music]
oh wow
what are you clocking in at over there
I'm about to let you get on here next
buddy don't even worry about it
come on now that's too much this thing
might be broke
if this ain't broke I'm
this got to be bro oh Lord
this broke I know that's broke
maybe it's broken yeah yeah that
broke go ahead you try how many pounds
you think you I mean what you think you
you're lucky about
two it's gonna be two something no this
is broken for sure okay there's no way
so you get this whole outdoor space you
get this full hot tub 25 million dollar
uh townhouse yes New York City and we're
just gonna assume that the scale is
broke out of this nice establishment
yeah I'll fix it before you buy it no
problem
oh